[Music]
in africa 650 million
people don't have electricity don't have
access to power
don't have access to an industry people
who would otherwise
have been very productive if they'd had
the means if they had the capital
it's really important that we don't lose
sight of these people
in our bid to grow our economies and
become more industrialized
one of the toughest problems in the
world is how do you bring people out of
extreme poverty
without wrecking the climate in the
process
conventional wisdom says it will require
the burning of enough fossil fuels
to cancel out any progress the developed
world makes on emissions
but here in rural kenya a small
experiment is underway to see if it's
possible to have the economic uplift
without the environmental catastrophe
what we're contributing here is the
potential to grow
so essentially no one is left behind in
the race to development
in the race to making our energy more
green
the first time i had power in my village
was in the year 1990
before that there was no power at all
completely
the the rule was set up the standards of
living were extremely
very very low zachary ayeko has spent
much of his career trying to bring
electricity to rural kenyan villages
like the one he grew up in as an
executive at the national power company
he helped expand kenya's electricity
access from 18
of the population in 2010 to 65
in 2018 the highest in mainland east
africa
[Music]
the kenyan government has done quite a
lot in
providing universal power but they have
not had enough resources
to be able to provide access to every
household in the country
the kenyans who have got no power are
based purely in the rural areas
once the electricity provided the
economic
empowerment of people goes very high
with millions of rural kenyans still
disconnected from power
a small green energy startup is
attempting to bridge the gap
power hive is the first privately
licensed utility in kenya
we currently operate about 25 uh village
level microgrids
we're generating our power from solar
we're storing that energy
in batteries when i started in this
business 20 years ago the price per watt
of a solar panel was five six dollars
now it's 20 cents
it's opened up a huge opportunity in
africa to deliver energy
a micro or mini grid like the ones built
by power hive
is a power system that supplies enough
electricity for a small community
schools and homes get electric light and
internet service
agricultural labor like maize milling
doesn't have to be done by hand anymore
electric pressure cookers eliminate the
need to chop down trees
or burn charcoal to make meals all of
these things raise the standard of
living
but there's one big problem when we
first came into kenya
we quickly realized that our consumers
are
too poor to pay for energy
[Music]
many grids have been around for a long
long time the problem is is that there
hasn't been economic models to support
the long-term
operations of these grids it forced us
to have to think about how
we can support our customers in
generating enough
income that they can sustain themselves
and then also create a good energy
customer for us as a businessman
in most rural communities in kenya
subsistence farmers would keep maybe 20
chicken
and these would be primarily for eggs
they might sell or consume themselves
really
but electricity along with some startup
capital from power hive
has changed all that powered appliances
like heat lamps and incubators can
transform chicken rearing into a
profitable business
it's a virtuous cycle for power hive
they give their customers the money
and guidance to start businesses that
use their electricity
and then a portion of the income from
those businesses pays for the
[Music]
electricity
foreign you also find that community
members who do see
successful businesses get inspired to do
that themselves
and all of that wouldn't have happened
if they hadn't had the exposure or
understood how it can be done or that it
can be done
[Music]
recently power hive has invested in a
new business
leasing electric vehicles to people in
the villages and in nearby kisi town
my name is bryan adobe i'm running the
ground operations for this ev project
in this region of kenya what we're
trying to do here is convert
all conventional bikes from petrol
engines to
electric motors
beyond just getting from place to place
motorbikes are key to generating income
in this region
where they're often used as taxi
vehicles or for transporting goods to
market
and while making the switch from gas to
electric is obviously cleaner
there are some more tangible benefits as
well
maintaining electric bikes is way more
cheaper than
maintaining a conventional bike in terms
of servicing
electric vehicles they have fewer moving
parts they don't require
oil you know here people are spending
around 10 us dollars every two weeks
for the maintenance cost so if we can
save somebody one or two dollars a day
it's a very very big deal the way we
have planned to
roll out the program is we'll be having
swapping stations
whereby riders around a certain area
could be able to
change batteries whenever they run out
of batteries and
the rate at which we'll be offering the
battery swaps will be much less than
what they pay at the pump for
fuel for the same conventional bikes
it's a brand new bike never been ridden
let's see how you like it you just turn
it on this is the
acceleration we've just introduced our
electric motorcycles
to a whole group of local riders
the market here has really really been
very receptive
namely because it saves them money and
because it performs better than what
they're used to using
it is so nice thank you
you're seeing this whole revolution i
would almost call it in terms of this
adoption of electric mobility
all over the world so it's just a matter
of time before
that adoption happens here and
everywhere else in the world i'm
convinced of it
it's still early days for mini grid
companies like power hive
and it remains to be seen how big the
industry's impact can be
a study by bloomberg nef found that
electricity from solar hybrid mini grids
is still expensive for many rural
customers
and the sector suffers from a lack of
investment
meanwhile large-scale renewables are
booming
bulk solar and wind are the most
competitive new sources of energy in
most of the world today
but with hundreds of millions of people
still living beyond the reach of major
grids
there's a massive opportunity to improve
lives without the climate paying the
cost
our business model if it works you know
can really change
what development means and what we're
trying to do
is create a model that can be deployed
anywhere
in rural communities across the globe
we have hundreds of millions of people
that are going to be joining the modern
economy
and you know these customers cannot do
so in a carbon
unfriendly way and here in kenya
we're showing that you can sort of
create this model which
you know we hope is actually going to
serve africa for generations
you